[Musique]
il
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture
aujourd'hui nous sommes à la maison aux
all à hamedan qui vient tout juste de
rouvrir ses portes après dix années de
travaux nous découvrirons également le
musée dreyfus aménagé juste à côté mais
avant cela voici le sommaire la maison
zola rouvre ses portes à médan après dix
années de travaux nous découvrirons
cette bâtisse avec l'arrière petite
fille d'emile zola est juste à côté de
ce site un nouveau musée consacré à l'
affaire dreyfus vient d'être inauguré
plus de 600 documents sont à découvrir
et puis enfin à versailles une
exposition sur le général de gaulle et
de général leclerc est présentée
jusqu'au 19 novembre l'occasion de ne
pas oublier cette partie de l'histoire
de france
il
[Musique]
je me trouve dans le salon salle de
billard de la maison le d'emile zola
celle ci a été acheté par l'auteur en
1878 elle disposait d'une ferme et d'un
grand potager et qui mieux pour parler
de cette maison et de ses grands auteurs
qu'un membre de sa famille martin
leblond auzolat bonjour bonjour est
l'arrière petite fille d'emile veut la
vie tout à fait je fais l'arrière petite
fille d'emile zola et parallèlement la
vice présidente de l'association maison
zola musée dreyfus qui est présidée par
louis gautier alors là on va faire on va
découvrir cette maison ensemble
mais avant cela est ce que vous pouvez
peut-être me parler des travaux il ya eu
dix ans de rénovation qu'est ce qui a
changé il ya eu dix ans de travaux
d'abord il ya eu des travaux de gros
oeuvre qui a été entrepris par le
cabinet jmr architecte a fait un gros
travail de gros oeuvre de clos et du
couvert et parallèlement il ya eu aussi
un gros travail de restitution du cadre
dans lequel je la vivais à l'époque
donc on a reconstitué le cadre avec le
mobilier qu'on a on a recherché d'après
des
photographies anciennes mais surtout il
ya une restitution aussi une
restauration d'objets décoratifs et
justement on peut aller voir peut-être
les vitres ou alors les vitraux de
gaieté ils représentent l'oeuvre de
babonneau un maître verrier qui ont été
réalisés en
1886 et isola beaucoup participé à la
réalisation de ces vitraux il ya une
importante correspondance entre lui et
et benoit disant je veux par exemple une
chauve souris je veux un élément un
grand pont et ses vitraux sont d'une
oeuvre magnifique et qui représente
l'art nouveau le symbolisme et qui font
entrer dans ce salon la nature zola
était très proche de la nature et 7 ses
vitraux représentent une nature
luxuriante avec des animaux parce que
cela a été un défenseur
fervent défenseur du vivant
des animaux et bien maintenant nous
allons aller dans le lieu de créativité
d'emile zola son cabinet
[Musique]
on se trouve dans le cabinet d'emile
zola là où il a écrit ses plus grandes
oeuvres martin leblond zola c'était
vraiment un lieu de créativité ici oui
tout à fait puisque zola venaient de
tous les jours dans son cabinet de
travail tous les matins ethnique rivet
pendant quatre heures de 9 heures à 13
heures et il était fidèle à sa devise
nous la ds signer linea aucun jour sans
une ligne cela écrivait l'équivalent de
quatre pages manuscrites en quatre
heures cela paraît peu mais en fait cela
ne se contente pas de décrire the l'a
fait entrer du lyrisme dans ses phrases
puisqu'il dit qu'il veut bâtir ses
offres comme une grande symphonie
musicale cela est un artiste avant tout
et ce cabinet de travail est-elle un
atelier d'artiste avec cette grande baie
vitrée qui donne sur la nature est ici
c'est son sanctuaire c'est c'est un
petit peu son ca toute ta tour d'ivoire
dans laquelle il écrit y vit ici avec
ses 1200 personnages loin de la ville
puisque cela s'est réfugié dans cet
havre de paix pour écrire ses romans et
s'imprégner de la nature avoisinante qui
le revitaliser alors là on peut voir son
fauteuil
vous savez quelle oeuvre il a écrit ici
alors là il a écrit des oeuvres comme
que me germinal la bête humaine
l'oeuvre pot bouille
et
la bête humaine notamment il s'est
inspiré de la voie ferrée le nom de son
de son jardin pour écrire la bête
humaine entre autres et il a même fait
le voyage sur une locomotive puisque
zola s'inspirait des lieux et il faisait
des gares ned enquête comme un
journaliste alors emile zola était aussi
un écrivain engagé on a pu le voir en
1898 il adresse une lettre à félix faure
le président pour réhabiliter un
officier juif français donc alfred
dreyfus est un musée lui est consacré
juste à côté du coût de cette maison
regardez nous sommes le 21 juillet 1906
le capitaine alfred dreyfus est
réhabilité dans l'armée française la fin
d'une injustice une véritable
machination judiciaire dont a été
victime le militaire ce polytechnicien
et artilleur de confession juive s'est
battu durant douze ans pour faire
éclater la vérité c'était quelqu'un de
complètement introverti complètement
inhibé quelqu'un qui était un
scientifique
polytechnicien et qui partait du
principe que l'émotion n'avait pas sa
place dans la discussion et que seule la
raison avait sa place quand on voit ces
deux photos là en fait sont deux photos
qui sont prises à quelques années des
gars là il est lieutenant de bande là il
est capitaine trois bandes en fait c'est
exactement la même photo il a la même
expression la même attitude exactement
la même manière de tenir son son sa tête
par rapport à ses épaules ses
photographies font partie des 600
documents à découvrir au musée dreyfus a
mais dans un établissement dédié à la
faire avec en perspective les destins
liés d'emile zola et d'alfred dreyfus
ses deux enfants de la république le
jeune italien zola puis de l'autre côté
l'israélite comme on les a l'époque
alfred dreyfus qui va devenir un
militaire qui était amené probablement à
avoir le plus haut grade possible et
peut-être même plus que ce à quoi il a
eu une carrière absolument somptueuse l
affaire dreyfus un moment essentiel dans
l'histoire de france avec des questions
autour de l'antisémitisme et du racisme
des sujets toujours d'actualité on voit
des images
racistes xénophobes et antisémites et de
voir que le slogan de l'époque c'est la
france aux français qui est un slogan
qui existent encore on le voit sur
beaucoup de murs c'était le sous titre
du journal antisémite la libre parole et
ça a été le principal slogan de quelques
partis politiques pendant pas mal de
temps et encore aujourd'hui à côté de la
maison zola le musée dreyfus a pris
place un hommage rendu pour l'éternité à
emile zola et à alfred dreyfus dans les
yvelines à mes dents
[Musique]
alors on vient de voir le reportage sur
le musée dreyfus martin leblond zola en
quoi et misola à jouer un rô le
important dans cette affaire mais c'est
dès lors que zola a eu connaissance de
l'innocence de dreyfus zola s'est
engagée
naturellement sur un plan viscérale pour
lui que c'est l affaire dreyfus était
d'abord un drame humain un drame un
drame humain et est également videmment
lutte pour la vérité et zola était un
humaniste avant tout et il a eu ce
courage ce courage c'est encore une fois
son action a été déterminante pour la
libération de deux de dreyfus et bien
merci beaucoup nous est il de vos aulas
d'avoir été notre invité
le salon histoire de lee revient pour
une quatorzième édition manifestation
incontournable à versailles ce salon du
livre propose des débats des conférences
ou encore des animations jeunesse samedi
20 et dimanche 21 novembre le
commissaire du salon nous en parler
[Musique]
oh
notre adn c'est bien sûr de rassembler
tous les historiens d'importance mais
aussi des passeurs des vulgarisateurs
voilà des journalistes qui se sont
passionnés eux pour un sujet qui ont
envie de le transmettre puis les
comédiens
[Musique]
cette année c'est un record historique
j'allais dire nous aurons cent
quatre-vingt onze auteurs présents
un peuple privé d'histoire quelque part
et et privés d'avenir et on doit
continuer à cultiver cette culture
historique tout toute sa vie
[Musique]
cette année on aura un grand débat
vraiment dédié que pour les jeunes plus
rond enracinée dans notre histoire plus
plus ils seront forts et bien dans leur
peau demain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes à 57 vidéaste qui ont
présenté leurs vidéos ou au jury et donc
il ya un prix du public tout le monde
peut sur le site histoire de dire point
fr votez regarder ses vidéos et choisir
son son meilleur vidéaste et le vendredi
19 novembre à l'ugc
ce aura lieu donc la cérémonie de remise
de prix et on reste à versailles
l'exposition de gaulle de claire
versailles est à découvrir jusqu'au 16
novembre à la salle des fêtes de l'hôtel
de ville il s'agit de la 7e exposition
mémorielle organisé par la commune
le général de gaulle et le général
leclerc deux figures de la france libre
durant la seconde guerre mondiale de
personnages historiques mise à l'honneur
dans une exposition à versailles nous
avons d'une part fait des recherches
dans les archives de la ville et nous
avons pu retrouver
des photos relatant la visite du général
de gaulle plusieurs visites du général
de gaulle à versailles notamment quand
il était président de la république
et nous avons pu retrouver pour le
général leclerc des ces traces de son
passage à versailles tous les ans autour
du 11 novembre une exposition mémorielle
a lieu à versailles plus d'un millier de
petites pièces et de documents sont
présentés vous voyez autour de vous il
ya des panneaux donc qui nous ont été
fournies par d'une part la fondation de
la france libre et l'association de la
2e division blindée nous avons également
sollicité les versets y est alors
certains sont de grands collectionneurs
donc ils ont pu vous trouverez ici des
modèles réduits des
des mises en scène de petits personnages
retraçant certains épisodes de la
libération de la france et notamment la
libération de versailles un devoir de
mémoire important pour cette famille
jean-yves bien transmettre à ses petits
enfants cet épisode de l'histoire de
france c'est un mélange à la fois de
deux textes explicatifs d'une part et
puis d'autre part de représentation très
exact d
uniformes des habits donc cela nous met
en situation
il ya beaucoup de
objets qui nous montre comment c'était à
la guerre et puis mon grand père il nous
explique comment ça se passe et tout
parce qu'il connaît il connaît tout ce
qui est en rapport avec l'émissaire le
thème de l'année prochaine est déjà
trouvé ce sera au tour du centenaire de
la pose de la première pierre du
monument aux morts de versailles édifié
le 11 novembre 1922
effet la fin de ces fuites culture merci
de nous avoir suivis rendez-vous au la
semaine prochaine dans un autre lieu
culturel yvelinois bonne soirée sur tv
[Musique]